thank you
foreign
problem session this afternoon so if you
have any good open problems that can be
presented
um like easily without much background
so if you create um so we're just going
to have an informal session where people
can come and present open problem
quickly yeah so I think it's nice if
you're open problem doesn't have doesn't
turn into a talk so something short that
you can describe and yeah and then later
people can contact you about why it's
interesting and a little bit more of the
background
[Music]
yeah thanks thanks for the invitation
and uh thanks everyone for coming to the
talk so
okay today I'll talk about
two-dimensional expansion of random
geometric complexes on the sphere and
this is based on joint work with sikilu
Sudan mohanty and Elizabeth Yang so if
you were here for the previous talk it's
like a it's like the rematch you know
this is like the the second um in sort
of a series of works but okay here we're
going to be uh asking questions that are
a little bit different than we were in
the last talk so uh I will start with a
story that's hopefully familiar about uh
expansion and then I will go to
two-dimensional expansion I'll introduce
that notion and I'll talk about
um our results
uh okay so
can you say that a graph G
is a gamma spectral extender
it's the second eigenvalue of its
normalized adjacency Matrix which I'm
just going to lazily denote Lambda 2 of
G is upper bounded by gamma and this is
interesting in situations where gamma is
strictly less than one right so if uh
gamma were one and then this would
correspond to the situation where
there's more than one component in the
graph when I say it's gamma is less than
one it says that there are uh not more
than one components in the graph and in
particular this is interesting when we
are actually thinking about a family of
graphs
gn1 for uh each uh and in the natural
numbers let's say are all insufficiently
large enough and we're thinking of n is
like the size of the graph the number of
vertices okay so if you have such a
family which uh our gamma spectral
expanders for gamma which does not
depend on N and is bounded away from one
then this gives you a bunch of
consequences for the graphs which are
pretty nice so like this means that for
example the graphs are uh like uh no
they don't have any sparse partitions
vertex partitions no sparse cuts
and you get that random walks
mix fast
so these are kind of useful properties
for a graph to have it's like a measure
of how well connected the graph is
um
and uh
uh okay so so and a priority like if you
never thought about expanders before it
might seem to you that in order to be
well connected it would be necessary for
a graph to be dense right so like if you
try to think about examples
the first example that might come into
mind is The Clique on N vertices okay
it's it's pretty easy to show that this
is an excellent special expander in fact
you can take gamma going to zero with
within
um but it turns out that actually uh
graphs with degree which I'm going to
denote by Capital Delta
order one exists so you know maybe the
first uh analyze examples of this were
uh uh random gracks even but but they're
also more structured examples too but
but here is a basically a theorem which
says that you know the property of being
a good spectral expander is really
really not rare at all
so here's a theorem uh and one side of
the theorem is due to alone
and the other is due to Friedman
and really I'm going to State the tldr
version of the theorem okay which
basically says that random
Delta regular graph
that's the best possible spectral
expansion
what's that probability
okay I could be more precise but this is
the tldr version
so uh not only are there constant degree
spectral expanders okay but actually
they're extremely abundant like most uh
Delta regular graphs will be really
really good uh special expanders
okay so that's that's the story for for
graph expansion and now the question is
what is true for hypergraph expansion
so
what is the parallel story
hypergraphs slash
simplicial complexes
so okay so I'll start by defining a
analog of expansion that will be true
which is designed for simplicial
complexes and for hypergraphs but I'm
going to Define it in terms of graphs
because I think if it's your first time
seeing this definition it's easier to
absorb it that way and if it's not your
first time seeing this definition you
know what I'm going to say anyway so
okay so here's the the definition
so I'm going to say that a graph
is a
gamma local
2D spectral expander
if it satisfies two conditions the first
condition that I'm going to ask for is
I'm going to ask that the graph is
connected
which is more or less what we'd expect
from an expander and then the the second
condition that I'm going to require is
I'm going to require that for all
vertices in the vertex set of V
if I take the graph
induced on the neighbors of this vertex
and I look at the second eigenvalue of
the normalized adjacency Matrix of that
graph then that is bounded by gamma okay
so this graph this graph induced on the
neighbors of inverse X this is called
the link
of the vertex V let's just do one or two
examples so that we have this notion in
our minds that we understand what's
going on right so consider for example
this
this graph
okay so in this graph uh let's first
consider what is the link of this vertex
V over here right so the operation that
I said I would do is I would look at the
neighbors of V
and I would look at the graph induced on
those neighbors so in this case the
neighbors of V are all of the other
vertices in the graph right and so the
link
V is just going to be two parallel
disconnected that is
okay let's uh let's also look at the
length of the vertex U okay so here the
link of you
could just be what so we take the
neighbors a view which are just these
two guys and we delete the rest of the
graph and we just get this Edge by
itself okay
so is this link operation clear
so usually
yes right this is a stronger definition
than the definition over there
now really like what okay so this is
what it means to be a gamma local
two-dimensional spectral standard and uh
you'll notice that like if I'm thinking
of every triangle in this graph as being
a hyper edge of order three right this
link operation is a reasonable uh uh
operation in the hypergraph right it's
just looking at all the hyper edges that
contain v you know deleting everything
else and then removing V itself and
looking at the graph that it leaves okay
so this is this is why this kind of
makes sense in uh in simplicial
complexes and in hypergraphs
okay so this is again a local 2D
spectral expander and instead of telling
you oh let me see okay let's let's look
at just one example any uh
any easy suggestions for an example
yeah the complete graph exactly that's
what I wanted to say Okay so let's just
observe that the complete graphene
vertices should satisfy this definition
at the very least right we have one
example that is easy to think about if I
take the complete graph on N vertices
and I look at the link of any vertex
that's going to be the complete graph on
N minus one vertices right I'm just
deleting that graph and looking at the
remaining graph so okay so and I already
told you that the complete graph was a
good spectral expander so
more satisfying the definition of a
gamma local 2D spectral expander for a
good choice of gamma
okay but rather than tell you uh and and
it turns out that there are examples of
uh
constant degree sequences of gamma local
2D spectral expanders but before I get
into that let me just tell you instead
of telling you any applications of these
objects like there's a whole uh program
right now that's uh heavily dealing with
with the stuff let me just tell you one
amazing theorem okay which which to me
is a really like a thing that makes
these objects very special
so this theorem is called the trickling
down theorem
okay and uh some version of this theorem
was proven by Garland back in the 70s
um more recently developed by oppenheim
and this urine basically says the
following thing it says that if gamma is
good enough in a gamma local 2D spectral
expander then Global expansion is
witnessed locally okay so it's saying
that uh if G
foreign
ER
for gamma
less than a half let's say the value is
half minus Epsilon
then
G itself is going to be a spectral
expander as well okay so if I look at
the second eigenvalue
not exactly of these agency Matrix of G
but of a version of The adjacency Matrix
of G in which every Edge is weighted by
the number of triangles that it
participates in
then the second eigenvalue will be at
most
gamma over 1 minus gamma which is a less
than or equal to let's say one minus two
Epsilon you can get a little bit better
than this okay so what this means is
that
if your gamma local spectral expander
for gamma bounded away from half then
you are also going to be a expander
meaning that like Global expansion is
witnessed locally
which is kind of a weird thing right
like in an expanded graph you know you
think of expansion as a very uh Global
property so it's pretty amazing that you
can have these objects where you can
witness Global extension locally I think
okay any questions at this point
so so here we are
we are okay so we were asking what was
going to be the parallel story for
hypergraphs and simplest complexes so
I've told you what 2D uh expansion is
and now we should ask you know
what are examples okay and is this
property of 2D spectral expansion rare
or abundant
okay so so uh uh noon
uh
sparse
spectral extenders
so we don't have that many constructions
of sparse uh 2D spectral expanders
so
the maybe uh Flagship example is the
ramano John complexes like sparsity
degree yeah so let's let's take a
variety of uh constant degree would be
ideal okay but I'm going to eventually
like move the goal post by a lot okay so
so the ramage on complex is
are indeed constant
degree these are analyzed by a couple of
groups of people Lee and uh Cartwright
hey
and Duke
and uh luboski
Samuels and vishna
all kind of in the early 2000s
okay so these were these were the the
only uh known examples of uh sparse uh
to do special expenditures which also
satisfy this trickling down theorem
condition more recently we've had a
couple of additional examples right so
we have um coset complexes
maybe the first work on this was by Tali
and uh
and a couple of Works uh came after that
and recently there's a there's another
example uh which which looks at Kaylee
graphs of random codes due to Louis
Govich I guess I don't see him in the
audience but you know he's he's around
um so in all these cases we have we have
uh sparse uh graphs but you know these
these are very very structured graphs
right they come from algebra in each
case there's some kind of group that is
lending structure to the graph okay so
the sparse examples we know come from
groups
and okay I know that one of the themes
of this Workshop is supposed to be
structure versus Randomness it's not
structured versus Randomness in the way
that I mean right now like right like
usually structure is Randomness you say
like an object you can decompose it into
structured in random Parts but here I
really mean like structure versus like
Randomness right like can we come up
with is it necessary for things to go
perfectly right in order to get a
two-dimensional spectral expansion
expander or could you come up with a
kind of higher entropy distribution over
examples where not everything has to go
exactly right right and still manage to
get this uh property so the question is
uh Are there natural examples
of distributions over 2D spectral
expanders
of course yeah anytime
all right
random yeah lifts
thank you really
okay
so this is a this is a another
Construction in which you start with a
really good uh with a really good
complex but then you can take a random
list of this complex similar to like
taking lifts random lists of of graphs
you can randomly lift complexes and also
get a constant degree
for the
for the comments okay but okay and so we
want natural examples of uh
distributions
over
to the spectral expanders
we're going to have two goals right we
want to have two things we want to have
sparsity on the one hand right bounded
degree as small as possible and on the
other hand we still want to kind of be
in the regime where the trickling down
Theory theorem kicks in and the local
spectral expansion is much better than
half right we want that we're in this
regime where Global expansion is
witnessed locally
so okay so what what's your first guess
of a of a thing to try here I mean like
you know like uh Delta regular graphs
worked pretty well for one-dimensional
expansion so why not two-dimensional
expansion okay so that's the first
that's going to be our first try so what
happens if you take Delta regular graphs
the links are disconnected so in
particular
if
the degree is less than root n
then
the links
are mostly
independent sets
right if I take a if I take a Delta
regular graph and Delta is less than
root n then in the neighborhood of
vertex I'm not going to see very many
triangles I will not mostly not see
triangles right it's going to look
locally like a tree with uh branching uh
Factor Delta or Delta minus one and so
now when I take the link of V right what
I get is I just get an independent set
this has the worst possible spectral
expansion the the this is only a one
local spectral expander which is just
like a trivial statement
okay so this makes us sad
okay that didn't work
now the next thing that you might try is
you might say okay there's depending on
who you are you might try different
things but one thing if you tries you
could say okay here there weren't any
triangles like no problem I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna take a air distrainy
hypergraph right so I'm automatically
going to make sure that there are a lot
of triangles that's not going to work
either
right so if you if you include every
hyper Edge independently with
probability p
again what's going to happen is that if
the average degree
is less than return
then uh
there won't be many examples of the
following thing
you won't have hyper edges
that overlap
okay this this structure won't happen
very often what this means is that if I
look at the length of the vertex it's
just going to look like a bunch of
disconnected
you know little butterflies like this
right and again the link will be
disconnected it's not like the the link
will no longer be an independent set
right it's just going to be like a
matching
okay this is a this is a computation
it's a little bit dull so I'm not going
to do it but you can check it for
yourself
so neither of these things went well
um okay a different thing that you could
do which which you say uh uh once uh
tried to do
is you could take a you could take a
Kaylee graph
the random generators
foreign
this is like maybe uh one way that you
can motivate this is you say well the
algebraic construction seemed to work
pretty well so let's try to have
something that borrows some of the you
know structure of an algebra and uh here
you can guess
graphs which are two-dimensional
spectral expanders in some sense and uh
the with degree let's say polylog in n
but
you only get half local spectral
expansion
okay so so you get graphs that have
non-trivial two-dimensional expansion
properties again I'm not I'm not going
to explain exactly what what uh
you know what what that means but in
some sense like we really wanted I
really wanted a distribution of graphs
which we in which the trickling down
theorem would kick in and these graphs
will not have the trickling down serum
kick in
so the motivation for this work is
exactly this like uh the the my kind of
structure versus Randomness right like
can I find a natural distribution uh
over sparser two-dimensional uh spectral
expansion expanders where the trickling
down theorem actually will kick in and
um my Benchmark okay I would have loved
to get a constant or poly logarithmic
degree but instead let's move the goal
post and just ask for something better
than root end since this is the best
that are kind of like natural random
constructions can okay good
foreign
okay and the idea for for this was to
maybe try to look at random geometric
graphs so okay so I'll Define a specific
class of random geometric graphs but the
idea of using random geometric graph is
a little bit more General as I'll
explain in a second so okay so here's a
definition so to sample a graph G from
the class of random geometric graphs
on the d-dimensional sphere which I'm
going to denote Geo and P with a
subscript of d
the first thing that you do is you
sample
vectors independently
from the uniform distribution over the
sphere in D dimensions
okay so I've got my sphere
I'm going to sample a bunch of vectors
so first I sample points
and the second thing that I do is I add
an edge
between I and J
if and only if the inner product between
the vector VI and the vector VJ exceeds
some threshold Tau
which I choose as a function of P so so
Tau
is chosen
such that the marginal Edge probability
of every Edge is p
alternative okay what does this what
does it mean in this situation I I just
take I look at V4 I draw the spherical
cap of measure P around it
foreign
for every Vector that fell inside the
spherical cap okay and you can do
exactly the same thing in any metric
space actually right you as long as
there's some notion of a distribution
over that metric space that you can you
can come up with right you you sample
points uniformly random and
independently in the metric space and
then you take a ball of a certain
measure around every point and you just
include edges for every other point that
falls and that's that ball
okay
so this is the this is the distribution
uh
okay the main thing that we're able to
do is we're able to prove that
these graphs and some parameter regimes
achieve uh the two-dimensional spectral
extension so here's a
here's our ethereum
so we're able to prove is we're able to
prove that for every Epsilon
there exists numbers C and Delta greater
than zero so that
if you sample a random geometric graph
in C Times log n dimensions
on N vertices and with Edge probability
one over hence the one minus Epsilon so
in particular this implies that
the average degree
and the maximum degree is something like
into the Epsilon
then with high probability
G is a 2d
hash minus Delta little
spectral alternator
like Randomness only and we want VN only
question about this does it seems
straight right there's a usual graph
theory if you make a geometric graph
like this it's gonna have worse
expansion properties oh yeah
okay what's going on yeah that's a great
question so it's crucial when I do this
that the dimension was chosen to be a
specific
logarithmic in end I mean I have a
narrow window of dimensions in which
this is going to happen it's very
important that I mentioned this
logarithmic again oh it's not like fixed
dimension
exactly so okay so let me let me say a
little bit more about this I think this
is a really great point so the study of
geometric random graphs is pretty mature
in the setting where the dimension is
fixed and you think of the number of
vertices going to Infinity okay but in
that situation the graphs have pretty
poor Global expansion and let me just
illustrate why would the with the
example where D is two right so I'm just
looking at the Circle
all right
okay so if these two right then
basically what I'm doing is I'm taking a
random discretization of the circle it's
gonna it's gonna look like this the
points are some kind of poisson process
on the circle right and then I'm
connecting points that are kind of
nearby
what is the spectrum of this guy going
to be like it's going to be like kind of
like the spectral of the spectrum of the
cycle in particular there are really
sparse Cuts right like the the half
space cuts are super sparse this will
persist for any constant Dimension okay
and it will only stop happening once I
take the dimension logarithmic an end
and now it's no longer the case that my
discretization of the sphere is so
faithful that the half space pets are
sparse like you would expect
um so this is a yeah this is this is why
this works but why do you need to down
the dimensions
dimensional okay yeah I ended up like
logging because Johnson initials or okay
okay so okay so so this is this says why
I need the dimension to be at least log
n and you're asking why can't the
dimension be larger than log n okay this
I can say something a little bit more
precise about this in a moment but
basically the the problem is that once
you uh once you take the dimension too
high your graph becomes more and more
similar to an air distraining graph I
guess this was said in the previous talk
uh and
the way in which okay so if the way in
which you're measuring how far is it
from being an area training graph is uh
in the global expansion notion then that
happens when the dimension exceeds
logarithmic and N so or okay let me say
something more I guess I can say
something more precise later but
basically if you want the dimension to
grow faster than logarithmic and N then
you're having to take the average degree
to be something like Ruden in order to
get expansion so that's that's the issue
original
okay that's a great question we don't
really know the answer I think the
answer should be yes but I'm analyzing
this was
I'll say more about it when I get to the
proof I'll point or I'll talk about why
the why the quite harder to analyze how
it is
okay one question you could ask is is
this type and the answer in the asset
side
so it's like you're not going to get a
better analysis of this of these graphs
unfortunately
with something else yes
I do hope to replace the spirit of
something else
yeah okay so so right so I've tried to
highlight that I said I I said
suggestively then you could have done
this with any metric States you didn't
have to start with the sphere you could
okay and I think that it's possible that
if you have that there would be another
metric space where instead of having to
take your average degree to be growing
polynomially and then right here we have
for any small like arbitrarily small
polynomial and we can get it but we
can't get it to be like n to the little
o1
otherwise we lose the Delta becomes too
small right and and I think that there
could be other uh metric spaces where
this might not happen and at the end of
the talk I will say like some
requirements that we know that these
metric spaces have to satisfy
other questions
like that was like not enough for
questions I was like I have questions
thank you
um okay
so I was thinking you can take just any
two Dimensions I think of the finals as
little trains actually
to prove them all together if you have
something that looks different food and
I can look at that and substance
yeah and ask yourself will you get
something okay yeah that's an excellent
question so so maybe uh so you can you
can take a existing uh High dimensional
extender
and you can turn that into a metric
space in some reasonable way the same
way that a graphing the final metric and
then you can sub-sample that and ask if
you're still going to get a higher
Dimensions matter I think the answer
should be yes in fact like the way that
we prove this will give one way in which
to
prove what you were saying if you were
complex satisfied certain properties
so I think there is a hope for that but
but like really like okay so
aesthetically what I was hoping for was
like a natural example of distribution
over to respectable standards and like
depending on what what you taste is like
natural may or may not include start
with a already like a ramage on complex
which to me I'm like already uh
not very satisfying
person then my question was
like is it really a random thing
this one
whereas so I was kind of wondering what
makes this construction much more kind
of rich
that's okay then we can now say we can
take it up yeah it's not big enough
okay but I think I think it's a nice
Bridge into what I'm about to say anyway
which is about how we approve this so so
let me give a couple of words about the
proof with an eyes where it's like
generalizing this construction to other
um
so
Okay so
basically what we what we did the way
that the proof works is we think about
the sphere itself like without
discretizing it
we should we show that in some sense the
sphere is a two-dimensional expander
and then we show that the discretization
inherits this property with high
probability as long as the graph ends up
being dense enough
okay so so our proof is really about
random restrictions
okay so uh let me Define what a random
restriction is
so
it's fancy h
is a graph
possibly infinite graph
then
we say
little H is an N vertex
random restriction
[Music]
if it is given
by sampling
vertices V1 through VN
independently
from let's say the stationary
distribution of a random walk on fancy h
okay for example if if your H was vertex
transitive then this is basically the
uniform distribution
and then taking uh H to be the uh vertex
induced subgraph
IES
okay that means that basically I'm going
to keep these vertices and all edges
between them and I'm going to throw away
the rest of the graph
this is an advertex random restriction
so my claim to start with in order to
motivate why I'm even telling you guys
this is that the this random geometric
graph
is in some sense and N vertex random
restriction of the sphere
it's not exactly but but of the sphere
in which I put edges between vertices
that y within each other's spherical Cup
right so if you take uh h
to be
the graph with the vertex set being the
sphere and D dimensions and the edge
step being the set of all pairs of
vectors u v such that the inner product
of u and v
is at least Tau
okay then
G from the distribution geometric random
graph and D dimensions and vertices and
Edge probability p is a and vertex
random restriction
of the stage
so what we're going to do is we're going
to study the properties of random
restrictions of graphs
and uh let's let's also unders like say
one more thing right so if I'm looking
at the at the link
of a Vertex V in the
random geometric graph distribution
right this is actually also a random
restriction
of H but where instead of taking the
vertex set to be the whole sphere I take
it to be a spherical cap
so I would take H to be a cap
around some vertex W of measure P
right and then the edge that would be
the same thing
right so but by studying properties of
random restrictions we're going to be
able to say stuff about the links and
that's how we're going to prove local
spectral expansion
foreign
I'll say the tldr version out loud and
then I will write the formal thing down
this is also due to due to us
so basically what this theorem is going
to say is that if I have a graph fancy h
which it has a sufficiently good mixing
of random walks
okay then that will be reflected in the
spectrum of a sufficiently dense random
restriction okay so if I have a a big
graph Capital H where uh we're in and
walks mixed super fast
then the spectrum of a random
restriction of this graph which is not
too sparse is going to be good
okay that's what that's what we're going
to say
so here is the theorem so
this h
is vertex transitive
pH
is the transition Matrix
or transition operator
for the random walk
on each
has a unique stationary distribution
and and this is the most important
property uh that uh
pH is contractive in total variation
distance so I want that there exists
C and Lambda
so that
for all integers k
and uh starting distributions View
the total variation distance
if I sample a point from you and then
apply a pH for K steps for a case of
random walk
the stationary measure is it most c
times Lambda to the k
yeah this is satisfied for example when
Capital H has a nice log symbol of
inequality so uh
if this holds then uh with high
probability
an N vertex random restriction
H has
second eigenvalue
of the normalized adjacency Matrix
bounded by
the maximum of Lambda right which is
kind of like what this this is the rate
of contraction of random walks in the uh
original graph and here I'm going to
have a term that's going to penalize me
if the graph ended up being too sparse
okay so here I have some kind of
polynomial in log n
and this see guy and then divided by
square root the expected
degree
of a Vertex in H
okay so this is saying that as long as
the expected degree is at least poly
login
the second eigenvalue of the random
restriction is going to bethmost Lambda
where Lambda was the contraction factor
for random walks in the original
manifold okay so the spectral properties
of the random restrictions uh are
inherited from the contractive
properties of random walks on the
original graph
did this does this make sense I know
this is a long theorem student
part uh where you compare the Lambda and
the folding login oh yeah okay okay so
so like really
that's a bad sign so okay so so really
the important thing here is the Lambda
okay right lamb is what I want you to
think but you it makes sense that if the
graph was too sparse like if H if I end
up if n is really really small and uh
like H ends up being really really
sparse and I shouldn't get any
guarantees about the second eigenvalue
so this second term here penalizes you
if the expected degree in h is too small
in your serum it's the second term for
order Lambda or significantly larger
than smarter than that it all depends on
it all depends on the expected degree of
uh vertex in yeah in your random
geometric spherical model oh Windows
Linda wins uh in the parameters
it's much larger in the parameter regime
that we consider
because because for us this is like you
know and to the Epsilon
uh and uh this is some poly login n and
the lambdas are constant so
so this end up this ends up waiting for
us
but it's also kind of like restricting
us from going Sparta in something if you
optimize it so the two terms are equal
you don't gain anything yeah yeah we're
not gonna get anything
I mean in some sense it's okay yeah
but it's it's okay it's making sense
right like uh
you could have something that's like a
fantastic expander but if you sub sample
an excess Sparks that you're only you're
not going to see any any edges you're
not going to get in the standard so
okay
so can you say something about why Logan
the great and is that the barrier
okay so like truly I don't think we we
didn't get the optimal
power of a vlogging here but in the same
okay so so uh yeah so I can say
something pretty concrete about why you
need at least some kind of Vlog if
you're going to do something like this
so okay so let's
take a couple for you think about the
sphere but what I'm saying is equally
true in in any method space right so
okay here is V1 let's say
okay and this is the neighborhood of
measure P around V1 right and the degree
of Z1 is just going to be how many other
points landed inside this neighborhood
okay so the degree
of uh V
is basically the marginal distribution
is binomial with n minus one trials and
that's probably and probability P so
that's probability p and you know the
the these uh degrees they're like a
little bit correlated with each other
but they're still not that correlated so
really what they behave like is they
behave like roughly like and roughly
independent samples of binomial with
parameter p
if this p is less than log n Over N then
we know that these don't concentrate
well and some of them are zero right and
and then you can't have an expander
because you have isolated vertices right
so it's the same reason that your
connectivity threshold for GNP is like
logging over in
that's what's going on here but inside
the joint component of GDP yeah so you
could you could say like well maybe if
we like erase all of the like little
isolated vertices and we like sniff all
of the trees off of the giant component
and a lot of things are nice and the
answer is like maybe yeah but like uh
you know that's for for future work
okay so it's a login seems necessary but
we're not even I guess like we're not
close to that for for other reasons so
this isn't the thing that limits us I
think
uh okay
all right other questions
okay looks like not so okay so now now
that I've done this this theorem and and
this uh about the proof thing maybe it's
it's uh it's uh hopefully what I'm about
to say next isn't going to come as a
surprise
okay so uh what is our strategy
we take
the graph fancy H for which we're going
to do the random restriction
to be
the spherical path
okay so really it's it's this graph it's
like
the grass where my vertex set is the cap
of measure P around let's say
without loss of generality the the
indicator Vector for this first
coordinate
okay and my set of edges is All U and w
with inner product
and I'm going to analyze what do uh how
quickly random walks contract in this
space and I'm going to apply that that
theorem
okay now uh
what is a random walk in this space look
like basically uh we're here
we're inside the spherical cap of E1
right and what does random walk look
like it's just it just I I start you
know I start here and then I hop to a
random
place inside the intersection of the
Capri on U1 and the cap around the point
that I started at right so like maybe I
go here and then uh you know like maybe
I go
here Etc okay so but what is this this
is really like applying successive
convolutions of a cap of measure P
around my current Point similar to what
um CP was saying earlier in her talk so
we just have to analyze the the
contraction properties of this operator
and we do that via coupling with
Brownian motion this is maybe not like
that it's a pretty clean way to do it
for us but maybe this isn't the only way
that you could have done it but anyway
we get results that are pretty tight
so okay uh
the a cool thing is that like the
spherical cap when the dimension is
large is not that difference from the
sphere
so more or less what we can do is we can
we can think about the sphere anyways
let me say
one more thing about that
okay so I've got I've got the sphere
and let's say that I'm I'm only
considering uh the Restriction to the
spherical cap
if D is sufficiently large then
basically all of the probability Mass
within the spherical cap is here at the
boundary
of the sphere okay so if I sample two
vectors U and w
uniformly at random
in this high-dimensional sphere they're
basically like we can think of them as
sitting on the boundary
so like we can think of you as basically
being equal to Tau times
one plus some perpendicular components
and we can think of w similarly this is
how times Z1 Plus
perpendicular component where these are
both
uh uniform
over a sphere of Dimension One smaller
right the sphere perpendicular to the
first coordinate vector
so
so more or less like when we're
analyzing the uh when we're analyzing
the spectral properties of this graph
it's enough for us to to analyze the
sphere itself okay then we're in a more
vertex transitive setting we have to do
some kind of hacks to like get over that
but that's not such a big deal this is
one of the things that's annoying though
if we want to analyze higher dimensional
simplicial complexes either like we we
did have to do this I mean you know here
it's like not like exactly we're in a
lower dimensional stream we're only
approximately in low dimensional sphere
if I was looking at the intersection of
two caps which is what would I what I
need to do to get the three-dimensional
expander then it would be more annoying
to do this hack okay not clear that it's
worth it since anyway we only get
polynomial uh degree okay
one players
what
so you can find the gas
yeah like oh yeah yeah we need to get
better that's true yeah uh
I think it might work anyway because
okay I'll say one more thing so why did
we manage to get from uh why do we
manage to get the half that's that's
coming in a second so okay so so the unw
that come from the cap
they're like coming from a sphere in one
lower Dimension but automatically their
inner product and their Edge probability
is boosted a little bit right so if uh
p is equal to the probability that two
vertices or two vectors A and B have
inner product at least Tau
let's let Q be equal to the probability
that uh
U and W having a product at least now
condition on U and W are both inside a
spherical cap
around the same vertex right what we
want really is we want the Q is much
much bigger than T right P was the the
Ambient Edge probability Q is going to
be the edge probability inside the
length right this is like the
probability that a triangle closes
and the whole point is that we want Q to
be large right like the average degree
inside each link so the average degree
inside the link is going to be NP
because this is the number of vertices
that fall inside the length times Q
right and this is better be at least one
otherwise we're never going to get a
connected graph and therefore we're not
going to get a good spectral expansion
so
so why are we able to to get this the
reason we're able to get this is that we
can relate Q to the uh to the
probability that two vectors on a lower
dimensional sphere have inner product
less than Tau okay so so why is that so
let's uh let's look here so as I said
like basically we can model U and W as
sitting in this level set they have they
have a Tau projection onto E1 and then
the rest is a random vector
and you can see that the event that U
and w
have inner product at least Tau with a
little bit of calculation this is
equivalent to the probability that
u-purp and W perp
have inner product at least Tau over one
plus Tau
so okay what's happening is that
the because uh if tau is large enough
right this is a significantly smaller
threshold that I have to exceed okay
like my I'm like moving the goal post
once I'm inside the link it's like not
that difficult to satisfy the inner
product uh
condition anymore and so uh if uh tau is
Omega one
The Edge probability
like two is bigger than V by a lot
this is this is where also by the way
the Hamad like answering your question
from before if the dimension exceeds log
n then actually tau is little o1 and
then this probability doesn't change by
very much so p and Q are roughly the
same order
and the condition that NP squared is at
least one is exactly the condition that
b is one over root n so
so this is a this is where this uh comes
up
I'm glad you're still awake to hear the
punchline okay so uh right so what was I
was I saying okay so if you were doing
the three-dimensional right like the
point is that once I take another
intersection things are even better I
expect it so I think things will work
out but I'm not really sure
um didn't think about it too hard
because as I said didn't seem worth it
to do
these packs
um
maybe I shouldn't call them hacks on
live television uh the okay so right and
okay just a parenthetical note right so
it turns out that uh for this graph
the parameter Lambda that we can take
is okay so on the sphere
for the Tau sphere
uh Lambda would be equal to Tau
and this is exactly if you go through
the computation you can see this exactly
satisfies the house right so this our
link eigenvalues are going to be Tau
over one plus Tau and our Global
eigenvalue is going to be uh Tau but you
can always see that this is less than
half this tau is less than
one
okay uh let's see maybe I should
stop talking about the proof and say
some stuff about open questions unless
there are questions from this
so here you can really choose any
position anywhere in the water on eight
yeah pretty much I like the one that
just uh
it just Maps into the uh into part
the one that directly takes you to buy
well
then it's like
backwards
restrictions so
that's fine
well it's the vertex in his subgraph so
like you'd inherit the weights too and
then I guess like if it takes you you
know like the Whopper takes you therapy
uniform distribution is like so it's way
to everyone so that I think I think it
would be true that you would get the
complete graph of computers
sorry that was probably too fast to
follow but
we'll take it offline yeah but um
instead of saying to the this so This
vertices on the cap for them
approximately on a sphere can you say
that they're exactly on the ball of a
slightly distorted metric it's like
sphere maybe on ellipsoid and then so
let's say that when you go to
links and sort of lower and lower
Dimensions you don't it's not that you
are approximately on some ball you just
change the notion of a baller but you
always
um yes but I think it will still like
the thing that the thing that's annoying
is that
um you're no longer in the vertex
transitive case and that will continue
to be true if you distort the metric so
like I think even if you phrase it
differently like the issue like the
Tactical issues that come up will be the
same it's not it's not the end of the
world to address them but it's like it's
kind of annoying
yeah
okay I'll try I'll try I have like a
couple of minutes left so I'll try to
end with uh some open uh questions
so I think okay really in my mind
there's like one primary open question
so some open questions came up uh from
the audience as we were talking like who
do you get higher dimensional uh
expansion not that I defined what that
was
um I think like another interesting
question is like co-boundary and
cosystolic expansion but okay so so
these are also interesting questions
which I I don't like I thought about
them a little bit I don't know how to
really answer them
but but I think this is the biggest the
biggest open question in my mind so
here's so here's the the main open
question
uh is
there another geometry
which is
half minus Epsilon or half minus Delta
let's see
local spectral expanders
oh
with
degree n to the little o one okay for
the reasons that I argued there I guess
like it's not reasonable to shoot for
better than logarithmic and n
but I mean we can only get uh enter the
Epsilon for fixed Epsilon
so this is a this would be like already
a major Improvement and it's also very
necessary if you want to take these
objects and use them downline in in
applications
um so okay so so this is the question
and we thought about this we've been
thinking about this question for for a
while and we can come up with a couple
of criteria that your geometry would
have to satisfy so I will say uh I guess
I have time to talk about one of those
criteria which comes with a nice picture
so okay so you must have
some curvature
it doesn't seem like necessary to have
positive curvature it could have
negative curvature but it seems like we
need the space to be at least a little
bit curved and in order to explain why
let me give you an example of a
non-curved space
okay so think about the uh here's a
counter example
which is going to be clear hopefully how
to generalize think about the Taurus
[Music]
in D Dimensions if you want to
but I'm thinking about the R by R by our
Taurus
in uh Indie Dimensions okay so so the
edges wrap around here right like this
this side view can identify with this
Edge okay let's look
at what the length of a Vertex is going
to look like
Infinity let's say Okay so
so here so here's the link of the of the
vertex
and suppose that the the side length of
the Box around this vertex is one okay
so the thing that dictates whether this
graph globally is a good expander is the
ratio between R and one
right if R is small relative to one this
expands pretty well if R is large
relative to the ones the expansion is
terrible
right just like the just like the grid
right like the the expansion of the grid
gets worse as you take the the grid side
length uh larger and larger
but if I just look at the length of a
Vertex here I have no idea whether R was
large or not right like just by looking
at local neighborhoods you have no idea
what the global scale of a graph looks
like therefore there is no way to
witness Global expansion locally the
links embed into a non-expanding graph
okay anytime where you have flat
curvature on your manifold you can take
the flat Direction stretch it out
keep the links the same okay and then uh
embed them I mean that's an and then
those links embeddington this that
non-expanding manifold okay so so
curvature seems uh necessary some other
conditions maybe seem necessary that
like take a little bit longer to explain
but um but I mean I'm still hopeful like
we uh every a couple of months we come
up with a new candidate that we're
trying to analyze uh here so if you have
any idea I'm uh open to hearing it okay
so thanks thanks so much for listening
[Applause]
questions
so what about uh I mean I know you cared
more about German stuff but let's say
clearly grabs if you look at the balls
around
this is like it for a while
group or something you actually have a
good expansion
it's possible it could work
sure
other questions yeah wouldn't you expect
from negative curvature like the
neighborhoods would be like Sparta than
we want rather than more like
concentrated worse
it's not clear that that's how it works
yeah maybe again like I'll chat I'll
chat with you offline about it but uh
but actually I have a little with the
opposite intuition like the negatively
curved space like locally things are
pretty good with globally meetings are
messed up
[Music]
I guess it will converge to this thing
right like this thing
the sphere like this version of the
series
yeah so okay then then I erase it but
like instead of doing that you put
that's
a decrease
oh but I mean if you so then you're in
the regime where you're fixing D and
then you're taking n larger market right
no I went I went into your life oh you
want and to grow along with it
uh yeah I'm not sure it's pretty similar
to how if you have a like oh it is
we don't actually have like uh
um
I don't think so but I didn't think very
much about it but I think I think the
answer is no should they have like
probably like sparse every single graphs
this this result your result shows that
you can separate distinguish right
between Mediterranean no but I mean in
this sense
I
think questions
not this thing